los restos del ex presidente carlos saúl
menem fallecido el domingo en buenos
aires- llegaron el mismo domingo
alrededor de las 8 de la noche aquí al
congreso de la nación argentina para el
velatorio en el salón azul el principal
salón de este palacio legislativo donde
menem era senador desde 2005 primero
estuvo limitado el velatorio a la
familia los más cercanos al expresidente
luego se sumaron funcionarios del actual
gobierno allegados y amigos del ex
presidente y más tarde alrededor de las
diez de la noche se habilitó el acceso
al público general que empezó a
despedirse personalmente del presidente
en a cientos de personas que tienen un
buen recuerdo de lo que fue su gobierno
entre 1989 y 1999 un tema de disputa en
argentina donde no todos piensan igual
pero aquellos que lo recuerdan con
cariño vinieron a despedirse a la
medianoche aproximadamente volvió a
cerrarse el acceso al público que volvió
a abrirse a las 7 de la mañana del lunes
y aquí vemos la fila de gente que
decidió venir a despedirse por la tarde
del lunes espera que los restos sean
trasladados al cementerio islámico que
se encuentra en las afueras de buenos
aires para que carlos saúl menem
descanse junto al cuerpo de su fallecido
hijo carlitos menem su unión que se
encuentra en este mismo cementerio en
las afueras de buenos aires